THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
AS PART OF ITS RUSSIA PROBE.
IT IS HIS SECOND TRIP BEFORE
THAT PANEL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CRITICS ARE
TONIGHT CHASING A NEW THREAT AND
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION PROBE.
IT INVOLVES A MEETING ON AN
ISLAND OFF THE COAST OF AFRICA
THAT THEY SAY WAS AN EFFORT TO
SET UP A SECRET DIALOGUE BETWEEN
THE INCOMING ADMINISTRATION AND
THE KREMLIN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS A
SPECIFIC SUM IS TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE RAKING DEMOCRAT SAYS
HE WANTS THE FOUNDING OF A
PRIVATE SECURITY COMPANY TO
TESTIFY FOR A SECOND TIME, ABOUT
A JANUARY 2017 MEETING IN THE
SEYCHELLES ISLANDS.
THE MEETINGS INCLUDE ERIC BURNS,
THE BROTHER OF EDUCATION
SECRETARY BETSY DeVOS, THE
CROWN PRINCE OF ABU DHABI, WITH
STRONG TIES TO VLADIMIR PUTIN,
ANTI-RUSSIAN BUSINESSMEN ALSO
TIED TO PUTIN.
DEMOCRAT SAID TO THE MEETING
CROSSED THE LINE.
>> THE SEYCHELLES MEETING WAS
PART OF AN EFFORT TO ESTABLISH A
BACK CHANNEL TO RUSSIA THAT THE
MEETING THAT ERIC PRINCE HAD
WITH THE RUSSIAN BANKER WAS NOT
HAPPENSTANCE, IS OBVIOUSLY AT
ODDS WITH WHAT WE HEARD AND THE
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
>> HAS 20 DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE NO
SUBPOENA POWER, WANT AN ADVISOR
TO ABU DHABI TO TESTIFY ABOUT
HIS ROLE BROKERING THE MEETING.
HE IS REPORTEDLY COOPERATING
WITH A SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
IN AN EARLIER TESTIMONY, ERIK
PRINCE SAID IT WAS A CHANCE
MEETING AND OUT A PLAN
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
U.S.-RUSSIAN RELATIONSHIP.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED FROM A
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN
RICE UNMASKED PARTICIPANTS IN
THE SEYCHELLES MEETING AND A
DECEMBER 2016 TOWER WITH THE